ngược cái này
tí tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ để ngược cái
này để tôi chỉnh lại cái mic
thự ra để ngay trước mặt của này Thực ra
hỡi vướng cũng chả biết được để cái này
đúng chuẩn chiều nó hay không nữa
vài cái
này à À đây là đường
link tâm sự à chia
bạn có thể xem và
gửi câu
hỏi
nhiều phết Ờ Thực ra từ mấy buổi trước
nữa câu hỏi
tí hôm trước trả lời vài câu rồi mà quên
ch
cái này bạn này chưa nhắn tin hỏi tôi
nên
là bạn có thể nhắn tin hỏi anh sau nhá
kiểu hỏi hỏi rõ ra ấy chứ đọc cũng không
hiểu lắm có hay đọc báo công nghệ tin
tức mới trong ngày công nghệ tin không ạ
thì tôi từng chia sẻ mấy ông mà thực ra
tôi không đọc nhiều lắm có theo dõi V
fanpage ở trên Facebook thôi
Ờ và tôi dùng cái tiện í kiểu à tiện xí
Daily dep này để kiểu thỉnh thả đọc thêm
những cái bài ở đây như có những bài
không thích thì mình sẽ kiểu ví dụ là
không quan tâm lên CS này chẳng hạn thì
bỏ đi
này không quan tâm đến cái au chẳng hạn
bỏ đi này th nó đề xuất những cái mình
quan tâm chẳng hạn Vân Vân đấy không
biết tế Trung Quốc
bỏi đấy
Ừ tôi tôi chủ yếu đọc trên mấy kiểu như
thế Anh chọn sự nghiệp hay tình yêu ạ và
Làm sao để cân bằng hai thứ cùng lúc
ạ Ông là hỏi cái này đấy để cuối giờ tâm
sự nhá
Ờ nhóm năm muốn làm về trang web công
nghệ mà chưa tìm template hiển thị bên
ngoài nó Ưng và đủ chức năng nếu
template nào xem nhóm anh được không ạ Ờ
tôi nhớ Tôi từng chia sẻ template cho
mấy ông rồi
Ờ tôi không nhớ cụ thể chính xác nó đâu
nhưng mà tôi từng chia sẻ rồi như thế
thì phải Ờ m ông xem lại cái link tôi
đính kèm Còn không thì chắc Ông nhắn
trên discord xem ai còn giữ hay không
thì thì người ta gửi cho nhá
Ờ Còn không thì trên mạng Thực ra cũng
có nhiều
tôi tôi thấy là cái việc code của cái dự
án này nó hơi bị kiểu chậm bởi vì thường
là nhiều Buổi tôi tốn hơi nhiều thời
gian và tâm sự quá là code ít th Bây giờ
tôi sẽ
và chuẩn chuẩn là kiểu dạng
Hồi trước thì chuẩn là mình sẽ code xong
rồi cuối buổi thì mình M sẽ tâm sự một
tí đấy nế là bây giờ tôi sẽ chuyển sang
là B cư cứ đầu mỗi giờ thì tôi sẽ ngồi
code tầm tiếng nên thế mỗi lần code thì
sẽ tầm tiếng xong
rồi cuối buổi tâm sự mỏng thêm sau trả
lời các câu hỏi các bạn sau các bạn có
câu hỏi gì thì cứ hỏi nha Thì để tôi
ngồi code đã
không thì cái tiến độ của cái này không
hiểu bao giờ mới
năng cơ bản rồi nhưng muốn xịn
A cái này tôi nghĩa là nó nên
a bắt buộc phải chọn một cái gì đó Khi
mà bấm thêm vào giỏ hàng chứ không có
thêm giỏ hàng kiểu như này
thế và à tăng số lượng lên rồi sao tận
có hai cái nhở
Ừ này như đang sai sai vậy b là
không xem
nào thêm và giỏ sao đây số lượng này
bằng 2 nhỉ đỉnh
thế
vậy header
này sản phẩm giỏ
không cái in đâu V nhỉ Làm gì có cái gì
In À đây là Mobile size 3
array season
C Ừ có vẻ cái giỏ hàng này nó đang bị
lỗi một cái gì đó nên nó số lượng nó bị
tăng đột biến rồi
tôi mở view ở đây
thôi mở controller ở đây xem là tốt
trang C chứ Mình đang ở trang C này Đấy
C controller
này Seon C à Bởi vì tôi đang lưu season
ID ở trong này Ok nên là đếm nó sẽ thành
hai
thì nó sẽ hợp lý hơn
này chắc là
được đâ Hình như có thể ghi kiểu này
được thử
nguồn tài liệu nào ngoài dog của larel
để học không ạ Không em ạ Có một sự thật
là như thế Anh làm cái này chắng chê
cũng kiểu có đọc để đọc thứ thứ đâu tăng
số lựa lên 2 Nhưng cái này là 1 đúng bởi
vì nó chể một product thôi đâ mình thử
sản phẩm khác xem có đúng không
nha đó tăng lên 2i đúng không Thằng này
bị lỗi mọi thứ kiểu dữ liệu kệ đi sao Ok
Bây giờ thì bây giờ mình muốn yêu cầu là
nếu nó có option thì mình sẽ chọn option
mình bắt buộc
phải bắt buộc nó phải chọn option thì
làm như nào
đang để default là rỗng này đây tôi sắp
xếp lại option xong rồi tôi nối để nó có
cái key như này nói chung hồi đấy tôi
làm kiểu này ky công phết Tại sao Có vụ
này bởi vì bây giờ tôi thử thêm cho mấy
ông như này thì mấy ông sẽ
hiểu
thỉnh thoảng này bị đơ T thông cảm thế
Mình sẽ chọn một cái option nào đó xong
rồi thêm vào giỏ hàng kiểu như này một
cái này đấy thì mấy ông sẽ thấy là một
cái này nhưng mà có option là xám và một
cái này như này thì nó sẽ là xám và
XL đấy hoặc là s đi chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ
là s xám rõ ràng mấy ông thấy là tôi để
là xám trước s sau Nhưng mà khi thêm vào
giỏ thì nó vẫn kiểu theo quy tắc kiểu
như này bởi vì mình có sắp xếp cái
option Còn cái việc mà còn cái việc mà
option hiển thị ra ở đây Thức ra cũng
sắp xếp lại cũng được Nhưng bản chất cái
này lưu lại trong TB theo kiểu là
product
option Lúc mà người dùng thêm vào
ấy đây product option lúc người dùng
thêm vào nên thành ra tôi đang hơi kệ nó
kiểu ch tự nào cũng được nhưng lúc lưu
vào trong bảng thì mình nên à lưu lại
trong mảng thì mình nên có một cái keia
ch nó đây tôi cho in ra cái key cho ông
để mấy ông dễ hình dung được nó đang có
key như thế nào ng mảng nhiều
chiều à quên này phải là thêm vào giỏ
hàng thì mới
đây đó mấy ông sẽ thấy là tôi có một cái
Seon ID này tại ạ tự nhiên có cái khái
niệm syston ID này bởi vì à
cái gì gì đó đỡ tí Tại sao tôi có khái
niệm syon ID
mà thêm ở giỏ hàng tôi đã tạo gần như là
nó một cái một cái đơn hàng nháp rồi cái
session ID này chính là đơn hàng nháp
đấy để về sau
mà để về sau khi mà tạo tạo ra đơn ấy
thì dựa theo session ID
này vừa rồi có tiếng Trung
không
ha có tiếng Trung ở đây này nick mình bị
hack
và Note anh đọp tài liệu đi nốt nhanh
hơn sử dụng ít tài nguyên hơn theo khí
cạnh nào đ phù hợp những dự án nào ạ Ừm
có những như mình đã nói Thực ra là nó
không quan tâm hẳn là về ngôn ngữ lắm nó
nhanh hơn thì nó cũng chỉ nhanh hơn một
tí không khác biệt lắm chỉ trong một vài
bài toán thì nó mới kiểu khác biệt rất
là đáng kể thôi các bạn quan trọng việc
là áp dụng ngôn ngữ Nó kiểu nó phù hợp
với cái bài toán tức C đừng đừng nói về
mỗi tốc độ mà nói thứ nhất là về thư
viện nó hỗ trợ này thứ hai nó tiện này
ví dụ là cả công ty bạn đều ai cũng kiểu
đều chuyên về p rồi chẳng hạn rõ ràng
làm pp nó lợi thế hơn đấy cái việc là
nói chung là
ờ ừ để mà lựa chọn một cái công nghệ nào
đó mình thấy là nó phụ thuộc nhiều yếu
tố lắm đừng quan tâm về mỗi tốc độ nếu
mà mỗi tốc độ thì thôi bạn chơi x cũng
được X là nhanh nhất đấy cứ chơi x bây
giờ rõ rng th cái codt kiểu web bằng x
các thứ đúng không Nó dùng ngôn ngữ khác
để tiện hơn các thứ các thứ thì bạn sẽ
hiểu lý do của nó đúng
không dự án này anh có up lên git không
chính xác là có nhưng mà mình sẽ không
Công kh công khai này được Vì như mình
đã nói thì nó là dự án này là mình làm
cho người bạn người bạn kiểu Đây là
trong web bán hàng của người đấy luôn
nên là th sẽ không công khai vở nó có
vài cái nhạy cảm nhưng mà tôi vẫn sẽ cho
mấy ông xem code này để mấy ông hiểu qua
thôi những cái gì nhạy cảm thì tôi vẫn
sẽ không cho ví dụ lên nhng phần đăng
nhập chẳng hạn còn cái về logic các thứ
thứ này Thực ra là mấy ông mấy ông đến
tầm cái xio mấy cũng sẽ thấy là cái này
cũng chẳng có gì đặc sắc cả Chẳng có gì
phức tạp cả đấy th Tôi chỉ đang hướng
dẫn cho mấy ông kiểu dạng là biết qua
Ừ thì như tôi vừa nói thì cái phần
syston ID này là để kiểu để mình Mình
gần như là lúc mà mình thêm vào giỏ hàng
đấy mình đã tạo một cái gần như một cái
đơn hàng rồi Đây là đơn hàng nháp thôi
thẳ qu mình chơi Lư DB thôi còn lúc mà
Lư DB mình sẽ dùng luôn cái này và cái
này phù hợp việc đây Lúc mà tôi nhảy
sang hẳn trang check out thì mình sẽ
hiểu là kiểu nó mình sẽ dùng luôn cái
season ID này này và mình sẽ cái cái cái
link này là link check out nhá Đây chị
mấy ông đây mấy ông thấy có link check
out này đúng không cái link checkout này
nó sẽ không phụ thuộc vào cái syst này
nữa đấy Lúc này nó đơn hàng thật rồi và
hoàn toàn là tôi thể vào ẩn danh như này
nghĩa là hẳn một cái Seon mới đúng không
Hoặc là dùng bằng trình duyệt khác ngườ
n một Seon mới thì vẫn sẽ truy cập được
vào cái link checkout này để thanh toán
đấy
yeah lỗi rồi ấ rồi Cái này đang lấy từ
lấy lại
từ
Seon
đoạn này Thực ra khôngn nếu mà giả sử
vào rồi thực ra vào đến cái trang thanh
toán rồi thì không cần hiển thị cái giỏ
hàng nữa cũng là một cách để mình đỡ bị
ẩn cái này đi thì đây là
If
này là trang check out
À đây đến lúc hỏi chity rồi
xống lar heer nhá
này Tôi muốn kiểm tra nếu đang ở trang
check
không hiển thị trong Blade thế
e request X này cũng hay
curent kiểm tra router Ồ đây này Ok thế
là
out ở đây nó có cả đằng sau có thể có
không Nếu mà ghi mỗi x kiểu như này nó
sẽ không đúng tôi nghĩ nó phải xộc à Nó
phải sao như này thì nó sẽ chuẩn hơn đấy
biết ngay báo lỗi nà đó mấy ông thấy
không đấy nghĩa là cứ miễn là Trang
check out thì cái nút này nó sẽ không
hiển thị ra nữa nên mình không quan tâm
về việc là kiểm tra dò hàng các thứ thứ
nữa
đấy hay không đấy đây xong rồi mình
điênn thông tin các thứ thứ Ôi lộ hết
thông tin ở đây
rồi chắc không sao
đâu
mà m Ông Không tìm được nhà tôi
Ồ
Ơ vừa rồi mình tắt cái CHT đi rồi à
không đây mở ấn danh mà đúng không Ừ
đúng rồi đây mở ấn danh B sao
giống cái cái này á Cái này là em trả
phí xong rồi em Có cái có cái tạo ở đây
này Đây explore này em tạo hẳn một cái
Cre ch TVT này để nó phục vụ mục đích
mình xong rồi em vào đây em trên cho nó
ví dụ Giả sử anh vào đây anh trên này
anh edit này xong anh sẽ trên dần cho nó
config kiểu em cứ ghi ở trong này là
kiểu thằng thằng bot này nó chuyên lên
làm gì các thứ thứ đấy thì nó sẽ dần dần
Giải thích ra ở
đấy đấy thì anh gần như anh đ có trên
được một cái con chity riêng
nhưng mà đại khái này nó cũng tương đối
đấy
Ờ gì
nhỉ Ok Ờ bây giờ hơi Lặc chủ đề tí quay
lại tí thì như tôi đã bảo thực ra là giả
sử giả sử nó có màu sắc hay nó có kích
thước như này thì bản chất là đương
nhiên là nếu mà có trường hợp như này
thì mình muốn mình muốn là kiểu nó bắt
buộc phải chọn nếu mà có option đúng
không Thì mình nên làm như nào thì ở đây
rõ ràng là tôi đang không hề vaad cái
đoạn đấy tôi chỉ có
set by option như thế
này lấy tất cả option ra nối vào lấy ra
giá Nếu có đợi tí đợi
có option này chạy lên lượt vòng lặp lấy
lấy từng option một
này để cập nhật
tình huống xảy ra đó là giả sử đây tôi
cứ tình huống trước là product này bạn
thấy có cả màu sắc có kích thước là nó
có sẽ có option đúng không ạ Nó là kiểu
như này mở nhầm rồi
hại Tắt bớt
bạn xem
product team slit này th cả Không biết
được nó là product nào chắc là cái
product cuối này bởi vì có XL đúng không
ạ Không thấy là có cái riêng xl được
tăng giá đúng không ạ mình xem với
product ID bằng 3 nhá Đấy thì rõ ràng là
nó đang có hai cái option ID mấy ông
thấy không ạ Có hai cái option ID đúng
không ạ
Và và giá trị các thứ thứ như này đúng
không Thì bây giờ mình cần ở đây đó là
là nếu mà sản phẩm có option thì bắt
buộc là phải chọn phải chọn option ví dụ
là có màu sắc và kích thước thì bắt buộc
là phải chọn một màu nào đó và chọn kích
thước nào đó không chuyện random đấy thì
không chuyện kiểu mày không chọn thì tao
cho Quang ngẫu nhiên không
thì ở đây mình sẽ nếu thế tức là mình
phải lấy toàn bộ option của thằng
product này ra đấy th đây sẽ là
product
Nếu mà có rồi thì tăng lên này Còn không
ở đây đây đây trong lúc Nếu mà không có
rồi thì tăng lên coi như là tìm thấy
được rồi tăng lên with này option
này đây tôi có We option đây rồi
gì
bằng
mình sẽ qu đây Ok như này cái d zit chọ
lại option chính là mình wit với thằng
option này rồi nên lấy được này Đấy xong
rồi
If option Nếu mà không tìm thầ như này
thì mình
sẽ TR cho một cái lỗi
luôn và không tìm thấy option nào
thường là à Không thường là run time như
này tôi sẽ không thích tôi sẽ trong
trường hợp này sẽ liên quan đến vad tôi
sẽ là như
theo kiểu này được nó phải with meit à
Hay with cái gì gì đó đợi đợi gì
truyền cái này
lại dùng CHT tiếp rồi Tôi
muốn tr exception file
edat
à trong code không phải nằm trong
nào v v option từ từ
nhỉ
hồi trước tôi nhớ Tôi từng dùng
tí còn không thì chắc tôi phải mở lại
code phải mở lại code ở trên công ty rồi
thông
cảm Chính Mình làm nhưng đôi khi chính
mình không
nhớ
V vator nhưng mà sẽ như này Quick m
lỗi được
option không tìm thấy nhưng mà như tôi
đang bảo thì nó là chuẩn là chuẩn thực ạ
không đúng lắm bởi vì mình cần
là mình sẽ cần phải ngược lại một tí đó
là nó là như nào nhỉ
này mới
mình
lấy cái này là param option nghĩa là là
người dùng truyền lên
đấy người dùng chuyền lên Đấy nó phải
như
nà Đợi tí Đợi
option màu xám
size
S à quên bây giờ giỏ hàng tôi đang đầy
hết rồi thc ra ạ không có tôi đang không
có cái nút xóa giỏ hàng nhanh đ chấp
nhận xóa hết đi nhá đây yeah lỗi rồi lỗi
này bởi vì cái head head Vừa nãy bị
lỗi đây header này này đây mình sẽ cho ở
đây Đây là Mạc rộng như này Ok tiếp tục
mua hàng
động thêm vào giỏ hàng luôn à đỉnh
rỏ hàng nhá
hàm này ở hai chỗ không phải mỗi chỗ này
gọi cả ở chỗ lúc mà xem chi tiết Tôi
cũng muốn cập nhật giá của sản phẩm nữa
Đợi tí Đợi
tí cập nhật giá trong trường hợp là
trong trường hợp mà nếu mà có truyền lên
cái A thì gì đó thì sẽ cập nhật lại giá
Ok
Đấy do tôi có hàm kia không sao không
sao
e ở đây ông sẽ thấy là có name này màu
sắc
này n màu sắc ở đây vẽ không đủ cho lắm
Đợi tí Đợi
tí mình cần lấy
không phải lấy ra
mà
à Bỏ DD đoạn này đi
mình thêm sản phẩm này vào giỏ hàng
tr tạm đóng hết đoạn này
khi bấm thêm là nó sẽ nhảy vào đây
này
đó nếu không thấy Thực ra lấy mẫu màu
sắc Tôi không cần lấy mẫu màu sắc mà tôi
cần lấy ở đây là tôi lấy
cái lấy cái
đây tôi đ đ hai cái này cho mấy ông dễ
hình dung nha Ok param mình truyền lên
giá trị là như nào Đấy mình truyền lên
là add kích thước là như nào màu sắc là
như nào đúng không ạ
này màu sắc là Xám này thì mình sẽ cần
phải mapping mapping cái này
lại Nếu thế thì tôi nghĩ là cái đoạn này
nên làm nọ phức tạp phết Đợi tí Đợi tí
định mế không thấy nó đang cố định là
như này thì mình để mình biết được là
cái option ID này đang là như nào thì
đang hơi
khó
sẽ chỉ có bảng product option không có
thêm bảng option nữa code là để đỡ phải
mất công nối như
này Nhưng thôi mình lỡ làm rồi để xem
varion ID nó à nhầm nó là varion key Nó
là một option key Tức là sao sẽ nối giữa
name của thằng này với
cái value này để tạo ra một cái ở ngay
đây này Nhưng mà chắc là tôi làm theo
kiểu khác đi tuân theo cái kiểu chuẩn
hóa như này đi thì mình sẽ cần lấy ra
một cái thang
option
rồi Từ đấy mình lấy ra được
product đây Đấy ra option này product
option
đầu
nó đau đầu thì nó khó giải thích ấ chứ
làm cái này thì cũng không khó lắm Thấy
không khó chn giản là đấy có màu sắc
kích thước như này thì mình nối tương
đương với các option nào để mình lấy giá
nó thôi đây mấy ông thấy không ạ Ở đây
à ở đây là màu sắc của nó như
này xanh xanh
xám Tại sao nó ở đây lấy ra được
cả
à đúng đúng đúng rồi Nếu mà như này
không được phải như này
đúng qut này qut
tôi lấy tất cả option produ option À đây
đy product option xong rồi phải nối đến
như này mới
lỗi
bởi vì mấy ông thấy ở đây rõ ràng sản
phẩm này product ID hạ bằng 3 như nó vẫn
lấy ra được thằng Hai Vì tôi lấy ngược
chuẩn nó sẽ phải như
được để tôi thử DD kiểu này cho mấy ông
dễ hình dung
hơn zit
đây đây mình truyền lên là kích thước là
s màu sắc là xám Đây là toàn bộ tất cả
option của thằng
product mấy ông sẽ thấy là bây giờ để
đầu tiên thì mấy cái thằng này này mấy
thằng này này mình không thấy là thực ra
nó đang hơi bất ổn một tí tôi sẽ dùng
cái dùng larel thôi Dùng cái larel
Collection để group buy nó đây nó sẽ có
group buy
đây group
bà tôi sẽ nhóm nó lại theo cái name này
theo cái name này này để tất cả nó sẽ
cùng theo qu name thì tất cả Kích thước
nó sẽ vào một cái tất cả màu sắc nó vào
một cái đúng không ạ thì xanh xám nó sẽ
vào cùng nhau đúng không ạ sau đó thì
mình mới kiểm tra xem là kích thước có
cái S hay không màu sắc có cái xám hay
không
đấy là một cách cách thứ hai thì để tôi
xem
bằng Tôi nghĩ là tôi cứ nhóm nó lại
ở đây
phải đau đầu suy nghĩ thế nhở hỏi ch nào
đến giờ lại hỏi cho GT rồi hơi lười động
não thông
cảo Tôi
rồi
lên đây là dữ liệu có trong database đấy
Viết đoạn code
để kiểm
tra để kiểm tra
option
có tương ứng với mỗi name trong
database và lấy ra giá tướng
à Lấy ra CH
tổng
Đúng rồi query trong forx và Joy hơi
nhiều hồi trưa code đoạn đấy Kiểu cho
nhanh thôi chắc chắn là đoạn đấy không
tốt đúng
không
Ờ không có vài trăm Motion thì ạ không
nhiều lắm
đâu Thực ra là nó cũng vèo vèo nhưng mà
Đúng là về sau mình phải làm việc với
cách rồi các thứ thứ nó tối ưu
option sẵn có trong dB
phải đều được gửi lên từ
thêm
tên Nếu có
name vào xong cái
đấy ghi đúng kiểu dạng là để cho
có ừ ok
ok Đúng Tôi nghĩ là khó mà nằm trong một
vòng lặp được chạy hai vòng lặp đó là ở
đây nó chạy vòng lặp này theo như mấy
ông đang hiểu là lấy dữ liệu từ DB ra
này lấy ra mấy m dữ liệu các thứ thứ
đúng không ạ xong rồi tạo ra một cái
mảng nữa Đây là toàn bộ các option có
thể có trong DB nghĩa là bao gồm cả kích
thước và màu sắc đúng không ạ
Đấy Xong rồi xong rồi tăng cái tiền này
lên cái tăng tiền này lên Tức cả như mấy
ông thấy vừa nãy tôi demo ấy đó là là
nếu mà giả sử mà khách chọn XL thì mình
sẽ tăng lên 30.000 Còn nếu khách chọn
các option khác thì không tăng lên tiền
đấy thì tôi là làm cái đoạn đấy là cái ý
là như thế nghĩa là có trường hợp là sẽ
tăng tiền là cái ch dve là nó tăng cái
kiểu tiền chân lệch lên ấy đấy thì nó sẽ
như th này rồi Tiếp theo là kiểm tra là
đây lấy tất cả các option trong DB ra
này xong đây có cái name này xong rồi
tạo cái biến ở đây kiểu cho có như này
có được kiểm tra không Nếu mà nếu mà lấy
từ request này và request này tôi cũng
kiểu cái key của nó chính là cái name
luôn K chả không tồn tại Đúng rồi đấy
code đạn này chuẩn đấy copy về thôi dễ
nhỉ kể
đến option đấy Từ ngem thế này ok
Ờ viator ex vừa nãy xong rồi đây sẽ là
rồi Quick myit vừa nãy tôi đây đâu rồi
tang để hết tiếng Anh
một mạng rộng như
lỗi
nhìn nó rõ
được an emm tin rất mạnh liệt
lỗi lỗi Tại sợ lỗi hả Tại
sao không tìm thấy đâu thử xem
à
lỗi là đúng ta có này
đâu lỗi tôi không
đâu thê Mà
giỏ Ok trông vẹ xịn đấy bây giờ đây ông
ông thấy mấy cái này được tích không Bởi
vì tôi truyền này lên mà
detail nữa nên thành ra trông cảnh báo
đò lòm này thôi th ra đang gọi bên đ
cũng gọi hàm này tạm tắt đi tạm tắt đi
gió không vào lỗi à vào lỗi
Ờ clen not
file Đợi tí Đợi
tí hay mình
đây phải DD lỗi ở đây luôn chứ
nhở Đợi tí Đợi tí ô option form DB này
chạy vòng lm này hay Có option form DB
không
là rỗng rõ ràng thằng này phải bắn lỗi
chứ
là cái m shit này đang
contr
à hơi
Tôi nghĩ là cứ th new run time vậy cho
nó
trả lời xịn hơn đúng không anh cũng
không hẳn đâu em đấy bắt đầu thiếu Chuẩn
rồi đấy chuẩn đấy đấy thấy thiếu kiểu
này chọn màu sắc nhá thiêu kích thước đó
chọn kích thước ok chưa đó xịn đúng
không chọn này ok rồi này Bây giờ giả sử
Xóa này đi
này cái này đang bị
tôi ghi đè lên thành abị này đang nãy
phải bỏ cái vụ ghi đè đỗi
tôi cái nút này đang bấm là nó sẽ ghi đè
lên cái cũ không thấy cứ ghi đè ghi đè
lên này lạc quan mà nói cái giao diện nó
không bị lỗi chẳng qua là nhìn trông cái
thách địa chỉ nó trông dài vãi trưởng
này thôi chứ là cũng phải sửa lại cái bụ
này
sử à Thôi bỏ này đi chỉ còn mỗi như này
thôi thì đây bấm thêm thiếu màu sắc ok
chưa xịn rồi
giỏ hàng là bắt buộc phải có màu sắc
đúng không
ạ
nhưng mà cái vụ này cái vụ này Thực ra
là chuẩn là nó chỉ là giả là lấy giá
thôi chứ không phải là để vate nên là
riêng cái kiểm tra vad tôi nghĩ sẽ là nó
sẽ là nên nằm
[âm nhạc]
ở một cái riêng một là thế hai
à đây tên là set try thì nó nên đúng mục
đích của nó thôi theo tôi nên tách hẳn
hai cái tách bạch ra cũng được Tuy là nó
mất công chạy vòng lọp và nhiều nhưng mà
nó sẽ hợp
lý
ex đơn giản chỉn Dạ sise
thôi Đây như này thì sẽ hiểu là cập nhật
giá thôi Còn cái này à V by option chẳng
hạn thì ở đây sẽ
là không quan tâm với giá
sẽ qu thêm cái
product option để lấy giá set này còn
cái này thì sẽ là một cái là
gì cả thì mình sẽ cập nhật
giá
này để nó là một mảng vì xong mình điền
được nhiều nó cũng
này chạy thử
request
bản
chất bản chất là anh đang muốn là việc
xử lý đang chỉ các bạn cách xử lý thôi
Đúng là mình thể ở ở đây ở đây nhá
thc Là cái hay của thằng
larel hay của thằng larel nhá Nó là một
Framework một Framework Tức là chỉ
là không bị gò bó cụ thể vào một cái gì
cả tức là hoàn toàn các bạn Thể code ví
dụ là như bạn kia nói thì mình cũng
thường hay làm đó là mình thích thì mình
code hết ở trong code hết cái phần xử lý
kiểu liên quan vies đúng không mình nằm
ở trong cái file request riêng tạo một
cái request ở đây xử lý đúng
không xong rồi ở bên trong này thì bản
chất là mình chỉ có xử lý cái mặt nghiệm
vụ mình thôi mình không cần quan tâm về
vi nữa chể chước đấy thì mình đang nói ở
đây nó nó là bài toán Đây là bài toán
đánh đổi tức cả đôi khi mình không clean
code được cái đoạn này Tại sao phải nói
không được Bởi vì cái này mấy cái chỗ
khác thì tôi lại làm nó đôi khi Thậm chí
không cần vad cũng được
ờ đoạn này chẳng qua là vaad bởi vì muốn
cho chặt chẽ kiểu mình phải biết được là
khách hàng mua gì kiểu gì mình cũng phải
vad đúng không ạ nhưng bởi vì cái này
cũng liên quan đến phần thanh toán nên
thành ra là nó cũng l bị oái ăm ở đây là
bài toán về tối ưu về hiệu năng nữa nên
nếu mà giả sử viad ở bên trong cái file
viad request kia đúng không ạ thì cái
việc dữ liệu sử dụng lại thức ra vẫn có
cách vẫn có cách nhá Tôi cũng có làm thế
ở công ty đó là khi vate xong ở file
request này tôi vẫn lấy được cái dữ liệu
từ cái chỗ request để sử dụng cho
controller nhưng mà nhìn thế thì không
clean code đó lắm tẹ nào cả nên là bây
giờ mình phải chấp nhận bài toán đó là
mình lấy dữ liệu ra rồi mình phải sử
Lựng sử dụng nó luôn Ở ngay ở trong
trong phần này Và thậm chí là mấy ông
thấy là đang có nghiệp vụ khá là nhiều
nằm ở trong mỗi cái tính năng kiểu thêm
ở trong controller thức ra cái này có
thể Tống một cái file Action nà
khác nhưng
mà ở đây Tôi đang chỉ mấy ông thứ nhất
là nó liên quan B toán đánh đổi đúng
không ạ Nó là như tôi vừa bảo nó hiệu
năng thứ hai đó là có một sự thật là cái
cái dự án này này nó cũng tương đối bé
khi mà mình bé mình không cần phải quá
làm phức tạp phức tạp theo kiểu là tách
nó ra thành nhiều Action xong rồi tách
nhiều layer repository hay gì gì đó
khiến một cái bài toán đang rất là đơn
giản tự nhiên mình lại mất thời gian để
ngồi cấu trúc các thử thứ khiến nó phí
to ra nó n ná giống như cái vụ nghe nói
là kiểu dùng dao dao gì Dao Dao chặt gì
CHT chặt bò đi chặt gà hay Tôi không nhớ
cái điệp khúc V lắm đại khái như thế
nghĩa là ră mổ bò đấy kểu thấy các em
chỉ bài toán nhỏ thì mình hoàn toàn mình
thể code sao cho gọi là chỉ quan tâm
việc là nó chạy được và hiệu năng tốt đã
còn việc à
à Còn việc là để cho clean code ấy ờ
clean code thì mình hiện tại thì cái
việc để đánh giá clean code ấy Thực ra
là có rất nhiều yếu tố yếu tố ở đây đó
là code của ông dễ nhìn hay chưa chứ
chưa Chưa cần nói việc là nó tách bạch
ra chỗ này chỗ kia nhá Bởi vì khi đôi
khi ông làm tách bạch thế quá nó clean
với ông đấy nh thành ra nó tính ra nó
vẫn khó đọc bởi vì kiểu ví dụ giả sử như
là ở công ty tôi bây giờ code để nhảy
vào
controller mình nhảy từ Router này sang
controller này sau lại nhảy vào bên
larel data này xong nhảy vào file
request này xong rồi nhảy sang cái
repository này xong rồi nhảy sang UK này
đấy thì thực ra đấy không phải là một
cái thứ gì đó dễ đọc qu lắm nghe nó hơi
bị nản đúng không Thì mỗi khi sửa một
cái gì đó Nhảy nhảy nhảy qua rất nhiều
cái lớp như thế thì thì để mà nói Thực
ra nó cũng không phải clean đâu nó nó dễ
sửa thì đúng nó dễ sửa nhưng mà nó không
hẳn clean hay kiểu dễ đọc
đấy Nên là ở đây có rất nhiều cái bài
toán Nếu mà giả sử Nếu mà giả sử Cái này
bị to quá theo kiểu một cái method này
này tôi thấy cái method này về cơ bản nó
vẫn đang bé nó chưa đến mổi 100 dòng Còn
nếu mà một khi mà method này nó quá 100
dòng chẳng hạn nó kiểu nó có quá nhiều
nghiệp vụ phải xử lý trong này thì tôi
sẽ tách nhỏ nó dần sang hẳn một cái
Action khác cũng được hoặc giống như là
bây giờ Ông thấy là những cái tôi vừa xử
lý ở đây là tôi đã tách nhỏ nó ra một
cái method riêng nằm trong cái mod rồi
nó cũng tương đối gọi là đỡ code hơn ở
trong controller rồi n tôi không Muốn
tách hẳn cả cái này sang một cái Action
khác trừ khi là nó bị phình to hơn nữa
đấy Đôi khi mình đừng có nghĩ kiểu nặng
nề quá về việc clean code clean code quá
nhiều khi mà cái bài toán nó không phức
tạp lên thế đúng không Bài toán này có
thể xử lý rất là nhanh tự nhiên ông phải
tạo rất nhiều cái file code để chỉ làm
xử lý một cái mà Còn không chắc là về
sau mình động vào sửa logic này lại một
lần nữa mình chỉ nên làm tối ưu cái kia
khi mà mình nghĩ là về sau mình sẽ phải
sửa lại đoạn này thì mình mới kiểu chia
nhỏ ra cho dễ sửa chứ một khi nó gần như
là nó kiểu cố định ở đấy mãi thì mình
thì nói thẳng luôn là code chỗ đấy hơi
xấu một tí cũng được miễn nó
chạy đấy đấy Thực ra là cũng phải nói
nói như thế nếu mà ông nếu nếu mà không
ấy thì ông sẽ không quản lý được cái quỹ
thời gian của Ông làm cái cái tas một
cái tas nào đó có nhiều cái tas mà nó
yêu cầu ông làm nhanh ông lại kiểu cứ
nghĩ phức tạp vấn đề lên quá thì sẽ
khiến cái cái tas ấy phải làm rất là lâu
đúng không Đấy xế tôi thường hay khuyên
tôi cái vụ đấy Đó là có khái niệm just
In Time tức là là M biết từ đấy không
nhỉ
là nghĩa là theo kiểu là kiểu cái gì đến
thì nó sẽ đến chắc là thế nếu mà dịch ra
kiểu văn vở tất cả Chỉ cái gì mà đừng
nghĩ đôi khi đừng có nghĩ kiểu đến tương
lai gì nó xa vời quá mình cứ làm xử lý
bài toán hiện tại đã và khi mà tương lai
nó sẽ xảy ra cái bài B toán nó xảy ra
Cái Bấc đấy đi chăng nữa thì lúc đấy
mình sẽ sửa nó sau và lúc đấy mình sẽ
tối ưu hay làm gì đó sau còn bây giờ chỉ
cần code cho nó chạy được đã Miễn sao là
đương nhiên vẫn clean code một cách
tương đối nhá chứ không phải code kiểu
code xấu rữ là code đểu các thử thử đấy
vẫn chuẩn format đã vẫn đủ test các thứ
các thứ cho nó đã còn về còn về
kiểu kiểu dạng là về sau nó thế nào thì
về sau mình và sửa sau Nói chung là mà
Ờ không đừng có đặt nặng nó quá hay kiểu
chỗ nào cũng phải clean code chỗ nào
phải tch các thứ thử ra thì chính ông về
sau cũng sẽ tự rối bởi vì thấy thấy là
kiểu tự nhiên đoạn này chỉ có một trục
dòng th tự nhiên tôi tách ba bốn vai thế
chẳng h Thế thì nó bị chính mình làm khó
mình thôi đúng không ạ
à Tôi nói thế không phải làá chỉ là là
làm thế là sai nhá như đang nói là mình
đấy là con dao hai lưỡi đấy nghĩa là ờ
cái cái mình tôi cũng qua cái chắc là
nhờ xếp tôi tôi chuẩn bị qua được cái
giai đoạn là chị là tôi cũng hạn chế
việc là nghĩ việc liên cốt các thứ thứ
tối ưu các thứ thứ nhiều rồi
Ờ nói chung là mình mình tránh bị mắc
vào cái bẫy đấy Cái bẫy lập trình viên
bị dính rất là
nhiều
Hay
phết
Ờ Ui cũng cốt tầm một tiếng rồi chắc cái
đoạn này đến thời điểm này chạy được rồi
Bây giờ mình sẽ chuyển qua tâm sự một tí
nữa nhá
Ờ Ừ chắc là kiểu tôi cốt cả ngày rồi mà
nên nên là tôi sẽ thường ha code chỉ một
tiếng mỗi buổi một tiếng xong rồi tôi sẽ
ngồi tâm sự với mấy ông nhở Ờ anh ơi Bây
giờ em mới bắt đầu học thì bắt đầu xem ở
đâu để theo kịp để hiểu anh đang làm gì
ạ theo kịp hơi khó bởi vì lúc mà em theo
kịp thì chắc phải tầm ít nhất là cũng
phải nửa năm nữa hoặc hơn bởi vì đây là
đang là series senio rồi
ờ
ờ thì em a phải xem cái khóa ít nhất là
khóa web cơ bản và thực ra khóa tấm hết
nhất của anh là là
SQL thì em thể xem tham khảo kiểu biết
qua về lập trình cũng như là kiểu mình
có thích nó Nam mê nó không k11 chưa ra
trưởng á xịn thế chưa trường nhưng mà
cũng chắc là cũng phải tìm hiểu trước
rồi các thứ thứ rồi các em bây giờ giỏi
lắm Bây giờ tôi còn phải nhiều bài toán
tôi phải lạm dụng
nhóm đang muốn làm à Cái vụ này vừa nãy
họi
có vaii cái ơ hôm qua tôi điền ở đây một
cái
lúc đấy chưa l à hôm đấy tôi đợi đợi tôi
một tí tôi nhớ tôi điền một cái gì
để mà không phải để hack Facebook đâ
rồi nhỏ tôi nhớ là để cw dữ liệu một cái
gì
đó
bằng
Ừ anh này anh không rõ mấy này lắm
thường có khi mấy ông hỏi câu câu đấy
cho bass hoặc Charity nó ra kết quả đấy
Bây giờ nếu mà cái cái câu hỏi của em
vừa hỏi thì anh sẽ chên về hỏi bass hơn
thì bass nó có kiểu nó tìm kiếm được
ngay trên web nó sẽ chuẩn hơn
Tôi định chia sẻ mấy ông Hôm qua tôi nhớ
cái chia sẻ định chia sẻ mấy ông cái hay
phết Nó không phải thủ thuật gì nó ghê
gớm đâu Nó chỉ giả là
kiểu mở request lên để copy cái request
để mà
kiểu làm làm gì cũng không nhớ không nhớ
cụ thể lắm cơ nhưng hôm trước nhớ cái h
tôi ghi lại trong điện thoại rồi Tôi xem
không biết được lúc đấy bởi vì tôi tắt
wii rồi không biết nó đông bộ lên
Ừ cái gì
à Hình như là CR cái trang cái
sinh của tôi thì
này của tôi không
sẽ lấy api từ cái trang này để
với code để buổi sau nhá buổi sau tôi sẽ
chia sẻ mấy ông cách
để CR lấy được ảnh từ trang này về nhe
vẻ hay đúng không
anh đấy Nhìn nhắc nhở cho nhớ ghi đôi
khi Ghi tắt quá chẳng hiểu gì cả
đây tôi chia sẻ mấy cái ở đây
để cái video này thực C thôi hơi ngại mở
cái này ở đây đại khái thì cái nội dung
của video này nó nói là kiểu dạng là cô
này đứng ở nơi công cộng xong rồi Kiểu
có cái biển là kiểu bạn thể làm mọi thứ
với tôi mà sẽ không bị kiện hay chữ
nhiệm gì cả lúc đầu mọi người kiểu dạng
là đi qua chỉ làm mấy cái kiểu nhẹ nhàng
đi kiểu là vuột mà hay th gì đó rồi Càng
về sau họ Càng nhận ra họ thể làm mọi
thứ thế ra là nó khá là may chưa đến nỗi
mình cái kiểu rất là ghê gớm nhưng mà à
thực ra có rất nhiều cái ghê gớm rồi bởi
vì ở đấy có đầy đủ những cái dụng cụ
theo kiểu là dao kéo h chỉ roi các thử
thứ lúc đấy mọi người biết được là có
thể làm gì ghê gớm cô đấy hình như đứng
đây Hình như là trong bao tiếng Ý đại
khái thì lúc đấy mới biết được là khi
con người mà không bị rằng buộc phải đặc
đạo đức hay là Pháp luật hay mọi thứ ấ
chúng ta thể làm rất nhiều thứ bởi vì
tính ra vẫn là người lạ với nhau mà thể
làm rất nhiều thứ tở nhau
nhiều diễn đàn
redit Nói chung là khá nhiều diễn đàn
nên là tôi cảm thấy
là cũng không bất ngờ lắm V
kiểu ở độu có người này người kia N
không bị bất ngờ khi mà có một cái tình
kiểu dạng là xã xã hội kiểu kiểu như thế
nhưng mà đương nhiên là mình cũng nên
nói chung là nó về đạo đức các thứ thứ
thôi Cái này tôi lưu lại nó rất là hay
nhưng
mà Mấy ông xem thì thấy cảm động thôi nó
kiểu dạng
vào một buổi tối người phụ nữ này bất
ngờ Nghe tiếng còi báo động inh ỏi khi
ra ngoài hàng chục xe cảnh sát đang tiến
về phía nhà của cô ấy khi nhận thấy tình
huống này cô ấy đã bật khóc nức nở nhưng
đó không phải là điềm xấu cô là một nhân
viên truyền thông của sở cảnh sát suốt
40 năm và đây là ngày mà cô ấy về hưu
những đồng nghiệp của cô quyết định tổ
chức một buổi tạm biệt đầy ấn tượng để
tôn vinh Cô ấy có lẽ Cô ấy là một người
tốt bụng nên mới được các đồng nghiệp ưu
ái như
vậy thỉnh thoảng tôi muốn chia sẻ những
cái vui vui kiểu nh Ờ vừa rồi không biết
tiếng có mở không trong khi đang vui vẻ
cùng gia đình vào một buổi tối người phụ
nữ
đúng
bị lướt tiktok nhiều trong cả cũng bắt
đầu nghiện mấy cái kiểu sót sủng các thứ
các
bạn nên tự học cách giải quyết câu
chuyện của bản thân mình đi nếu như
không giải quyết được thì các bạn nên a
nghỉ ngơi một hôm để nghĩ lại tôi nghĩ
là tôi sẽ phải mở mấy cái video này ở ẩn
danh
xuất nh là nếu như mà lớn rồi thì các
bạn nên tự học cách giải quyết câu
chuyện của bản thân mình đi nếu như
không giải quyết được thì các bạn nên
nghỉ ngơi một hôm để nghĩ lại cái hướng
giải quyết cho nó hợp lý cảm ơ Tôi thấy
chả có ai có thể giải quyết được vấn đề
của mình vàng bản thân mình cả có là
giải quyết theo hướng như thế nào thôi H
vọng là là mọi chuyện nó tệ hơn th ra
câu chuyện mà nó đã bị thì nó đã trải
qua rồi Vấn đề ở thời điểm hiện tại là
nên giải quyết hậu quả và lần sau không
gặp lại những cái vấn đề đấy nữa vấn đề
Rắc rối đấy nữa để mình lỡ phải đau đầu
nếu như mà một câu chuyện mà lặp đi lặp
lại đến lần thứ hai là bắt đầu mình có
biểu hiện bị ngu rồi đấy Và nếu như mà
còn lặp lại đến lần thứ ba nữa thì mình
ngu vãi lìn rồi ai dẫm hai lần thấy
là do con người bộ não phát triển và
update lên chứ đúng
không
cái này Thực ra nó giống Tuy nhiên là nó
là một mấy cái chửi các thứ thứ rồi
nhưng cái này giống cụ cũng cụ tát C hất
gọi gì gáo nước và vào mọi người nghe và
cụ thể cả tôi tôi gần đây khá nhiều vấn
đề có rất nhiều vấn đề kiểu Mình có thể
chia sẻ tâm sự được có thể kiểu nhờ
những người xung quanh chợ giúp được vốn
từ trước này tôi vẫn tự tin là là tôi ít
ra tôi có gọi những người thân những mối
quan hệ xung
quanh nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy gần đây là
kiểu nhận ra điều là đương nhiên là họ
không bao giờ luôn ở bên mình đúng không
Mình vẫn tự lực đứng lên đặc biệt là gọi
như nhà th mình vẫn là cắt hàng con trai
mà Tức
cả mình không thể
kiểu mình khó có thể kiểu yếu đuối Mị
các thứ các thứ mình vẫn phải tự mình
giải quyết và tự mình đối mặt
thôi Nó n ná khiến cho có cái
video này thì
phải như có một cái video gì
đó trước gương jia tự
nhủ Thế thì chắc là tôi không lưu lại ở
đây
rồi
cảm thấy không có đam mê với cái này
cũng là một cái chi thâ giờ em không đam
mê nó th em làm cái
thôi Ok Nếu em không đam mê với nó cũng
chả sao cả nhưng vấn đề Nếu bâ em Em
muốn làm gì em định làm gì đấy là cái
điều em phải nghĩ trước khi em nói câu
chuyện là em không đam mê nữa giờ em
muốn bỏ học đúng không Rồi em bỏ học rồi
em làm gì nữa Em không đam mê nữa học
đúng không Ừ thế em nghỉ nhưng nghỉ rồi
làm gì nữa nhà em có sắm cho em mấy con
bò về chăn bò không hay em về em làm bán
hàng tập hóa nhỉ Đây nó phải là điều
quan trọng mọi người phải nghĩ đến điều
đấy chứ không phải là bây giờ em chán
học rồi Tôi thề với các bạn từ hồi lớp 1
đến lớp hai đến cấp một cấp hai cấp ba
cho đ đại học tôi không biết bao nhiêu
lần tôi chán học rồi Chưa bao giờ tôi
Tôi cảm thấy là tôi đ là một cái người
đam mê trong việc học hành cả nhưng tôi
vẫn phải học đó là cái điều gọi là cần
điều kiện cần cho mọi thứ Tại vì giờ nếu
mà học tôi biết làm gì Chẳng nhẽ
bảo là Đị mẹ Hồi đấy tôi Tôi chỉ nói một
câu là Ừ không học thì đi đánh đệ tử à Ừ
đánh đệ tử rồi sao nữa có đánh đệ tử
được cả đời không đánh được bao nhiêu
năm
nên trước khi mọi người muốn làm cái gì
đấy Mọi người phải đặt câu hỏi tự đặt
những câu hỏi đơn giản trong đầu mình
thôi Thế bây giờ chán học rồi thì muốn
bỏ học đúng không Thế muốn bỏ học thì
làm gì đấy nó chỉ có câu hỏi như thế
thôi làm gì kiếm được tiền không sống
được không phát triển được không được
thì ok bỏ học hết còn nếu mà có một
cái định hướng gì cả thì thôi học đi Ít
nhất đấy là một cái thứ mà mình chán
nhưng nó là một cái thứ hiện tại nó định
hướng cho cuộc đời mình còn hơn là đi mẹ
đi làm những cái thứ mà mình biết là
nó đến đâu ngày hôm nay nó ở đâu ngày
mai nó ở đâu và nó được bao lâu thế thôi
chả có gì phức tạp cả tất cả mọi thứ
trong cuộc sống những câu trả lời nó rất
là gần với cả anh em bạn bè rất là gần
bản thân mình chỉ là chính là chúng ta
tự làm khó chúng ta thôi khác thằng
fuin đi bắn csgo đâu các bạn chẳng khác
gì đâu nhưững việc rất nhiều những việc
rất là đơn giản trong csgo thằng fuin nó
làm cực kỳ đơn giản thì là xong như nó
không thích thế nó thích làm ngược nó
thích thế nọ thế kia rồi mọi thứ nó
thành phức tạp lên và cuối cùng nó
đến đâu cả và nó làm ảnh hưởng đến người
khác thế thôi chúng ta Cuộc sống cũng
nên là như
vậy
Ờ ngồi ng tôi tôi biết được nghe anh
văng khá là nhiều T không tôi thực ra là
một con người văng rất là
nhiều nhưng mà khi đi dậy đương nhên sẽ
cách nói chuyện kiểu
khác nhưng mà đi khi đỗi khi chúng ta
phải
nghe kiểu nghe nghe thấy rất là thật mà
đúng không Đấy do mà tại sao họ được
nhiều người theo dõi anh anh bomman này
hay là anh Độ này tôi không nói là kiểu
tấm gương là chúng ta phải nên văng
nhưng mà đang nói là kiểu y ra họ họ
không giả tạo họ nói
thật tôi Tôi cũng không rõ được về sao
tôi sẽ văng tục hay không khi mà kiểu
như thế này chắc là khi tâm sự Chắc là
có còn khi dạy nó sẽ là một kiểu khác có
thể sẽ cân nhắc nhưng mà tôi không hẳn
là muốn một kênh của mình là một con
người kiểu nghiêm túc V lắm N không định
hình là như thế
Ờ Còn về câu chuyện vừa rồi đó là
Ừ Nói chung là hai video đề là hai video
kiểu cũng gáo nước lạnh vào mặt cả để
mình tự thức tình Bởi vì tôi thấy là
nhiều bạn đến ngày hôm nay tôi vẫn thấy
có bạn nhắn tin cho tôi hỏi là kiểu em
A em muốn đi học hoặc là thậm chí em
chán học hay vân vân hai người hai hai
cách nói khác nhau một người muốn đi học
thêm bởi vì không tìm được công việc một
người chán học cũng là bởi vì cảm thấy
là công việc mông lung Cả hai đều dẫn
đến một kết quả đó là Mung lung và không
đi được đến đâu cả thì thứ c
thì như cái video đầu có nói đó là chỉ
chính các bạn mới cứu được các bạn thôi
Cho dù tôi có khuyên các bạn như nào nữa
tôi thể định hình các bạn được như nào
nữa thì các bạn cũng sẽ tự mình cứu mình
khi mà các bạn biết được là mình phù hợp
với cái gì cũng như là
là cái ý chí của các bạn đủ cao để các
bạn tự cứu mà thực ra là với tôi quan
điểm ý thực ra là nhiều người thường hay
nói đó là tôi cũng hay hay khiến các bạn
bị ỉ lại
quá nghĩa là những bạn Mà đang gọi như
những bạn tầm tuổi như này tầm tuổi kiểu
đang ở trên trường ấy hoặc là sắp ra
trường ấy thì vẫn còn chưa trưởng thành
Tôi cảm thấy là thế chưa đủ chưa đủ bản
lĩnh để trưởng thành chứ đủ bản lĩnh để
va chạm nên là mới hỏi những cái câu như
thế bởi vì bởi vì nếu mà Giả sử bạn bị
đẩy vào bước đường cùng theo kiểu là
không còn lựa chọn nào để l lui ống như
là bây giờ vừa rồi anh chia sẻ hay các
thứ ấy chỉ tự mình cứu được mình ấy thì
các bạn không bao suy nghĩ việc là bàn
lui hay là dùng từ chán trong công việc
các thứ vì năm thì có
chán không làm cái này thì làm cái nạ
không làm này thì còn cái gì để làm nữa
chỉ chỉ chỉ tự mình cứu mình thôi đúng
không Lúc đấy các bạn sẽ có góc nhìn rất
là khác Lúc đấy đương nhiên là cũng sẽ
trân trọng có thể trân trọng tôi như
nhiều người từng Bảo Trân trọng tôi khi
mà tôi hỗ trợ được các bạn à các thứ các
thứ chứ không phải kiểu dạng là những
cái những cái gì mình chia sẻ miễn phí
là coi như người ta không trân
n một video nhẹ nhàng nốt cuối cái này
chắc là nhẹ nhàng hơn rất nhiều này
trước gương jia tự nhủ rằng bản thân
mình đã thực sự may mắn Tuy kiếp này cô
không còn nhiều thời gian Nhưng mà nếu ở
lại một lần nữa thì cô nhất định sẽ cười
nhiều hơn yêu nhiều hơn và nhìn ngắm cả
thế giới mà không sợ hãi trong bữa tiệc
mừng năm mới kragen đã tiết lộ toàn bộ
về jia bằng một thái độ cực kỳ khinh
thường nhưng mà điều đó không làm cho cô
thấy hổ thẹn mặc cho lời căn ngăn của
bếp trưởng cô đứng dậy thừa nhận danh
tính của mình jogia đến đây không phải
là để gây ấn tượng mà chỉ đơn giản là để
tiêu hết số tiền mình đã kiếm được trước
khi nhắm mắt xuôi tay cô đã cố gắng giữ
bí mật này để cùng mọi người vui vẻ cô
đã có những trải nghiệm tuyệt vời tại
một nơi đẹp đẽ cả một đời cô đã im lặng
và sống âm thầm giờ là lúc để sống hết
mình tận hưởng hết mình và chơi hết
trước gương
Ờ Đây là video của The reviewer thôi hiy
vọng các bạn à Nếu có thể các bạn thể
xem cũng rất là hay đây video tóm tát V
phim à Nếu mà có thể xem cả bộ phim cũng
được thí là tôi cũng chưa xem hẳn cả bộ
phim này đầy đủ nhưng mà nó hay ở điểm
rất nhiều hiểu cho bạn hiểu cái đoạn vừa
rồi là như bà này có chia sẻ vừa rồi là
bài kiểu sắp mất nên thành ra là bà ấy
kiểu đến đây bà hưởng thụ thôi nhưng mà
mọi người cứ tưởng bà ấy giàu nên thành
ra kiểu Mọi người muốn làm quen các th
thứ thế như thờ các đ bà chỉ muốn hưởng
thụ tận hưởng hết mình cuộc sống của
mình thôi
mình phải dùng từ ân hận bao giờ cũng
không được ân hận vì mình đã sống như
nào hay Ấn hận vì mình đã bỏ lỡ điều gì
Vân vân cũng như là đấy sống hết mình
các thứ làm việc hết mình làm việc hết
mình n hơi quá nó phải chơi hết mình nữa
n Đừng chỉ ngồi cầy và làm đấy Nói chung
là rất nhiều người đang để tôi cảm thấy
là đang để thời gian trôi qua mình đang
làm mọi thứ giết thời gian nữ thực ra nó
không hàng ngày mình làm nó làm đi làm
lại công việc đấy nhưng mà thực ra nó
không cải thiện thêm được gì cho mình là
khiến ch mình càng ngày càng thêm mệt
mỏi không cảm thấy được sống ấy thì nó
không tốt theo tôi
thì nói chung là tôi tính là bởi vì tôi
may mắn n tôi là tôi làm được đúng cái
thứ tôi thích là nó vẫn kiếm được tiền đ
là một thứ rất là may
mắn Nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là ai cũng kiểu sẽ
tìm được một cái gì đó Mình thích và
mình có thể theo đuổi được vân vân
Nói chung là nó vẫn do bản thân mình
thôi đúng không
ạ Thôi buổi tâm sự hôm nay kéo dài phết
Ờ các bạn có câu hỏi hay gì và xem buổi
sau tôi sẽ tâm sự gì nữa Chẳng h Thế thì
xem ở đây nhá vể form câu hỏi các thứ
thứ này Hoặc là nếu các bạn ngại thì các
bạn vẫn có thể inbox riêng cho tôi để
tôi trả lời và tôi hỗ trợ Chữa bài tập
cho các bạn bạn Ok chào mấy ông
nhỉ Ở đây không hỏi thêm gì đúng không
nhở dự án này có làm với Podcast Không
anh à dự án này chắc là không em ạ